When my husband requests tacos for dinner,
I take it very seriously
because I don't wanna fail his Mexican roots.
And authentic taco starts with the quality
corn tortilla,
and store bought just won't do.
That's because your typical
grocery store corn tortilla is made from GMO corn,
and then it's loaded with gums and preservatives.
I'm going to next analyze regeneratively farmed
heirloom blue corn,
which is a process that involves
cooking the dried corn with water and cal,
then letting it sit overnight.
After washing the corn to release debris and skins,
I get to grinding the corn into masa.
I'm using a hand cranked Molino first,
which will get me a chunky masa,
but then I'm going to move to the.
This is the tool that ensures the masa is super fine
so that the end resulting tortillas are soft
and flexible and bursting with flavor.
And now it's time to shape the masa into tortillas.
I'm using a tortilla press,
although you can also just use your hands.
With a bit of practice
you'll be able to get quickly round tortillas
because that's really important.
Storing the hot tortillas in a towel while you make the
entire batch helps them to soften up even more
so they're bendable for tacos
just like the ones at the store.